emmanuelle béart bonsoir ce qu'ils ont
vu le film à commencer par moi vous
trouve lumineuse et sensuelle
si l'enfer est peuplé de si jolis
visages au signe tout de suite
georges henri sur ce coup zoo qui avait
commencé ce film était lui-même très
jaloux claude chabrol qui a beaucoup
étudié la question a une très bonne
formule vous demander si vous êtes
d'accord vous savoir la firme il est
clair que l'on est jaloux parce qu'on
est fous et non l inverse
oui moi je dirais que je crois que la
jalousie et une n'est pas une preuve
d'amour c'est une preuve de manque
d'amour pour soi même avant d'être une
folie la jalousie c'est un peu comme un
train dont on ne peut plus donc un peu
plus hautes et c'est un train qui va de
plus en plus vite et on saute quand on
peut paul ne peut pas là on est vraiment
dans la pathologie cirque on vous
racontera évidemment pas la faim fait
mais ça se termine de façon très très
bizarre c'est vraiment une jalousie
pathologique maladive tous les groupes
mensonge en un dieu merci il ya
plusieurs il ya plusieurs degrés il ya
une véritable évolution dans le film
c'est effectivement un couple qui
commence qui un couple qui a tout pour
être heureux de gens de jeunes gens de
province qui s'aiment passionnément et
qui s'embarque sur un grand bateau un
bateau où il ya du soleil oui à la mer
et puis tout d'un coup ils vont être
happé leur histoire va être happé par
une histoire qui n'est pas la leur qui
est probablement celle de paul et c'est
bizarre parce que je regardais ses aînés
ces images que ce que je n'ai pas vu le
film depuis longtemps et je me disais
que ça ferait ça me faisait encore mal
parce que je suis amoureuse de ce couple
je suis amoureuse de cet homme de cette
femme et je les trouve très émouvant
tous les deux ils parlent vraiment pas
de moi ni cluzet je parle de paul
ennemis libre vous faites vous partie
des 25 % france et qui s'avoue jaloux
dans leur vie conjugale est malgré tout
et oui moi je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
mon temps parce que je n'imagine pas
qu'il ne puisse y avoir que 25% g7
jaloux je sais pas je trouve oui mais
c'est ce que tu dis
c'est bizarre c'est comme un sujet tabou
les gens n'osent pas dire qu'ils sont
jaloux
moi je dis que je suis jalouse mais dans
des normes normal c'est aussi un signe
de manque de manque de confiance en soi
vous le disais tout à l'heure
oui mais il ya dans il ya encore
évoquent plusieurs degrés dans la
jalousie moi je m'arrête à la première
station pour reprendre l'image du train
je suis jaloux c'est aussi la jalousie
peut être aussi une forme de deux de
séduction un jeu d'amour entre deux
personnes
et puis je me dis que comment imaginer
que l'être qu'on aime le plus au monde à
qui on trouve toutes les qualités ne
peut pas plaire à la terre entière mais
le problème c'est pas ses accesseurs
c'est de savoir si la terre entière lui
plaît le banal open n'est pas un peu
jaloux lui aussi quand ils vous voient
flirter avec marc lavoine qui est très
mignon et qui dans le film est votre
amant supposé daniel auteuil n'a pas vu
le film à voir et n'a pas lu le scénario
donc ce n'est pas posé la question mais
je crois qui a je crois qu'effectivement
c'est un sujet qui peut qui peut
concerner les gens qui regardent qui
s'est avant tout je dirais qu'avant
parler de jalousie j'ai envie de parler
d'amour parce que il ya effectivement un
manque d'amour mais en même temps chez
cette femme c'est cette petite bonne
femme qui est à bord une femme en font
un site pour devenir une femme mère une
femme femme quelqu'un qui sera embarqué
dans un bateau et qui voudraient
fabriqués avec sa force de vie son
instinct de vie débarque pour les sauver
parce que ce qui est très beau c'est
qu'elle y croit jusqu'au bout et c'est
que lui dans ses rares moments de
lucidité des moments qui sont de plus en
plus rares se dit qu'il va ils se disent
qu'ils vont s'en sortir parce qu ils
sont deux et parce qu'ils s'aiment
merci beaucoup longue vie donc à ce film
qui démarre demain sur nos écrans un
film je le disais très troublée très
dérangeant avec une fin qui va sans
doute perturbé pas mal de spectateurs
mais plutôt c'est pas plus mal et
puisque c'est la ceinture d'aujourd'hui
bonne fête à claude chabrol